all I know is I that's me that's all of
me No Country for Old Men boy on bike
into - yeah my first audition
my first job could have quite possibly
been my last job as I saw it is most
definitely my last job not to say
anything against Jolin either his
choices and casting me but I thought the
fella was quite perfect up into a boy on
bike number two rolled up with Boyle and
bike number one who was wonderful bone
sticking heavy rock all right let me
just sit here a minute
we had the old brother where art thou
soundtrack on quite often to that film
it come out and was available on you
know and a wide spread to be bought and
heard so we had that soundtrack and and
I knew that movie but that was all I
knew yeah I didn't think there was a
chance in heck that that was gonna
happen I never read the script either
but my mom said it was very good she
quite preferred it to the book for the
painting I believe said it got down to
it you know really kept going if it
wasn't for that job I wouldn't have
become obsessed in the way I did with
film
I loved filming was obsessed with film
in a certain kind of way
for directors but after being on set
that just it really changed everything
at how I never saw a film again the same
way and I don't think I can ever again
but yeah it was very important through
for me Kate look sweets here the Last
Exorcism I got that job with my Texas
agent Linda McAllister had to go to New
Orleans drove with these two guys that
we probably would never get along in
normal circumstances one guy was
auditioning for it too and the director
Daniel took me outside after the
audition
and the other kids were waiting like
hours for me because I was like one of
the last ones to go and I really fussy
about one of them was fussy about how
long it to take him and the director
runs out he says Kayla I was really
great but you're stoned and this was at
a time when I wasn't smoking in the
morning or in the afternoon or in the
evening
only at parties or something or in a
tree house or something when someone
else brought it you know digging it out
of their sock or something
he thought I was stoned and I said no
sir no I
I've gotten stoned before but I'm not
stoned it was a long trip and I wish I
was but I'm not sitting well would you
mind coming back up and doing that again
of course absolutely but let me go tell
the buddies they were really angry with
me just please give me 15 15 minutes
yeah yeah no more than that okay great
but that was a great experience because
there was no script except for
guidelines more or less what the scene
was or what was happening physically but
we got to come up with the lines and it
was really just had an objective that's
the first time I had more than one scene
so got to hey I'm gonna gonna play this
scene this way now oh this can happen
and I can now feel this way about it wow
I'm gonna try that and it kind of worked
perfect right yeah we're going the wrong
direction you want to make a u-turn
actually okay you want to take this road
go straight you see things you racing
before keep on going then I hit the high
over him okay and then I want you to go
back where you came from that was the
first time someone really let me kind of
bring something and really got to have
fun with it even though it wasn't a fun
process biting me is very lonely sticky
there were like three auditions and I
think we had an idea that it was x-men
but didn't know what the character was I
was just thinking a lot about Jack
Nicholson in the audition for some
reason I remember practicing at my
buddy's Jesse's house while they were
playing songs and drinking I was working
on this audition that I think was x-men
but wasn't sure and I remember it said
he screamed and I thought man that's one
way to really not get the job you know
is by coming and going ah you know it's
loud as you can you know I trust you
until I don't trust him say nothing I
want to die all right we're not gonna
make you do anything you guys
I'm sure you've talked to people that
speak about the harnesses and stuff that
they use and they're very restricting
and I think it's it's the more an actor
knows about what they're involved with
sometimes the better and later on I
wondered if I could have helped out with
some things that I I don't know little
movements and things that if I had seen
in a larger scale I wonder if I could
have helped just by a shoulder dipper
the smallest little things are turn
faster here something that maybe could
have been a little better but but you
don't know much as an actor got to work
with late Phil Hoffman and John Turturro
and people have been dreaming to work
with four since I saw their work and
found myself watching always their work
and that was playing bad guys is funny I
don't know I was having no trouble with
not knowing if you leave the character I
still don't know what to do that film
was strange because it was dealing with
a very racist character a very
misunderstood very angry character a
very blind very stupid very narcissistic
and so I I tried my best to be that for
a good month and I hope it works out you
know another role where the character
hated his family that was more fun than
some others because I think he had fun
even though I remember at one point like
I think I remember like feeling I had
the whole family in me like every single
one of them and I remember puking out
every single one of them calling them
all out by name including like some of
the people that were working on the film
and Jordan and stuff like calling all
the way and I getting them as far what
body as I can
that was weird you an anime fan what
what
hey Jeremy why don't we let someone else
have the floor first okay
he's dating my sister you had your
chance I can't get too low the guy never
met Jordan before and spoke to him you
know briefly on the father the script
was was unlike anything I've ever seen
yeah I couldn't even think of like a
b-movie
you know what I mean that like would
have been in the 80s or something I
couldn't think of anything I haven't
seen too many B movies but I've seen a
few do you feel towards outside that
because they're very very welcome read
for her son first you know went okay
apparently and Martin gave me a job for
that for that part and then the film
didn't happen for a while almost two
years something I was working on in the
middle of working on get out actually
and and Keena was helped me out with the
audition and she made me leave and do it
again and come back because Martin asked
me to audition for the red Welby
character because he thought now that I
was too old for it
and absolutely it was what I thought
from the beginning was I don't know
because he's in high school still and I
always hated how you got the James Dean
in the high school you know I mean some
of those actors really helped me a lot
in that process I don't know what I
would have done without a few of them
saying this and that here and there just
make me believe in myself once again and
okay come on man get on with it you know
ken yeah it's the contract says looking
over at all the lawyer says so to her
when you need this next payment by read
oh now really three billboards owes I
mean once again like God's pocket I was
working with so many people that like
man if you told me I had worked with
them all in one film I had a
get out of town you know no way Jose I
thought flicked beans right in your face
with a spoon and Martin McDonagh script
was perfect me and everybody working on
that film was great from costume to
camera to [ __ ] everyone was top not
just great at what they do and for me
there's a lot of reasons why I think
that one is very important to me
American made baby Tom Cruise is another
one that is amazing to just stand there
you know just in the same room with them
cuz he's a movie star you know and that
was the first time I'd ever met anyone
that it affected me but I didn't realize
I'd looked up to them as much as I did
or they'd affected me as much as they
did and so your heart is beating and
you're going whoa that's not cool man
and this person and that much control oh
it's a physicality right now you can
talk to the goddamn lawyer
what are we going man I got the slam
doors and flick him off then there was a
blast you know I got to come to work
with blasting Alice Cooper with my shirt
off in a rental car I mean that was the
best man going away you're gonna go tell
Tom Cruise dude come on man you gotta be
joking and then I'm gonna blow up jack
I left another phone went over there for
two days
it was very fast and I'd read the script
and I loved the script and I team
tangerine and I loved this idea of this
film all coming from this perspective of
these children and you know this wild
place you know full of full of great
Wonder in great danger
and then this character Bobby and
[Music]
dealing with him and then knowing that
Dafoe was playing that and knowing hash
yeah Shawn it was the baddest films kind
of knew what to expect to some degree
that was great and everything crew was I
mean they're great and everybody running
around it was like it was beautiful and
the whole thing was happening 24/7 is
what it felt like it felt like there was
no start and stop it felt like it was
happening 24/7 whether or not cameras
wrong or not you know the whole thing
was alive and that was great but it
literally just got the mint stepping in
and going you know Wow and then you got
to go okay they put me up in that with
the nice Disney Hotel you go guys don't
pay to go to this place but if you can
ever sneak in somehow I'll get someone
else to pay go because they got
fireworks in the night time chess pieces
big is I don't know why I as yourself
but wild plays kind of creepy piece
Stephen B dream-come-true more than even
some other of the dream come true and
another kind of way watch n Eraserhead
the first time and having to shut it off
to go do something is good man that's
good I'll tell you all about the tenants
and in between I'll show you how much I
love you and I'll tell you how beautiful
you alright I'll tell you
I wonder sexy you are I know I do things
wrong a lot of course I felt the
pressure to get it right
you let me do that whatever that meant
very few people do this for me and he's
one of them and so to get to be a part
of that is an absolute honor I don't
know exactly I was getting into it at
the same time I did because I talked to
Josh on the phone and he told me thank
you but what we'd be doing really the
only question was how depending on how
certain people feel about each other I
always let friezes go about
destructively figure that I had to do
that and I regret a lot of choices that
I made but at the time that's all I knew
had to do yeah it's all real I mean it
wasn't real it's all real and it wasn't
real he was a real man he's no longer
with are you home if you loved me you
would have killed yourself by now really
if you loved me you wouldn't killed
yourself by now so why are you still
here
yes as much as we could take from what
was going on while also trying to
reproduce what had happened
it was unbelievable I've never done
anything like that still for me it set
me up in a way that allowed me to go
about the process in a way that I'd
never that I've been allowed to go about
in the hotel room or on my own on the
street but never with other people
especially in a city you know just
dilution and I've always tried to
contain it and that one was there wasn't
you couldn't do that and so that changed
a lot of how I worked later I think -
there hasn't been a job that I've been a
part that hasn't been important or that
hasn't that hasn't meant something and
taught me and changed me in some way
whatever every film has done this and
I've been so [ __ ] lucky and blessed
to have this grievous way